the Biden Administration has no answers
literally watch this some illegal border
crossers are being given court dates in
2031 what are they supposed to do here
for 7 years again that's a better
question put to the DHS I'm not in a
position to to talk about specific cases
like that the president believes that
we've got to do better at immigration
and he's willing to talk and negotiate
with members of Congress about
immigration policy just as well as he is
about border
security Biden and can't get to the
Border but Sarah Carter is on location
in EOP Pas Texas the site of some of the
worst illegal immigration she joins us
now along with former senior adviser to
president Trump Steven Miller welcome to
both of you Sarah you heard the report
from Bill malan hi you heard the report
from Bill maluan uh walk us through what
you're seeing an Eagle pass and why is
it one of the worst places right now for
illegal
immigration well it's certainly an area
Kelly uh right behind behind me I have
probably around 1,500 people that are
still being processed through so you ask
the question why is this area so
imperative well it's because it's an
area controlled by trafficking
organizations the drug cartels own this
part of uh the the Border they move
people in with impunity they are running
on the opposite side from Pedas negas
all the way up to Mata moros and
straight down the line to lukeville
where uh where we have Bill maluan um
they utilize this area to move through
because it's easier for them they also
know that border patrol is going to be
processing the people that they are
pushing through uh this is what's so
incredible it's as if the Biden
Administration is aiding and abetting
the drug cartels and the human
traffickers it's like they're working in
syn and we've seen it all day Kelly I've
been watching busloads of migrants
illegal immigrants come in and then
they've been pushing them out and
sending them out on private buses to
other parts of the state where they will
then push them out into uh airplanes
some of them are private some of them
are are commercial aircraft like Delta
American Airlines we've seen that all
online um where they take them out and
they fly them out to cities like
Philadelphia I think the biggest concern
right now is the special interest aliens
as well these special interest aliens
that are coming from Molly from sagol
from Bang from other areas of the world
like Sierra Leon are not being properly
vetted they are coming into the country
um and they are being set free and even
if we run background checks on them
Kelly if they pass a background check in
the United States which they more than
likely will they'll be let go and this
is what is concerning to law enforcement
here on the ground as well as
intelligence officials that are
monitoring this situation in the FBI all
the way to overseas when we're dealing
with CIA and other Western intelligence
agencies that say that we are putting
our nation in a massive predicament and
we are exposing our citizens to a
national security threat that is
unmeasurable Sarah it really is
incredible and you can find your way
there but Joe Biden and his borders are
K Harris somehow can't uh and Stephen
Miller I wonder why that is I mean
clearly President Biden has great
political risk here if he doesn't have
the compassion if he doesn't have the
guts and the courage and the strength as
our commander-in-chief and our president
can he actually look at what a liability
this is for his election since the
Democrats seem to care most about that
and um kamla Harris too I mean Stephen
you remember when we were in the white
house together KLA Harris and eight or
nine other Democrats running for
president in 2019 went to a teenage
migrant facility in Homestead Florida
and this is what they do they prein they
Pander they pretend to care about people
while they're running for president and
KLA Harris went down to Homestead
Florida I'm going to call for the tweet
that she put up after that in June of
2019 so we can say it she said I went to
the homestead detention center to see
firsthand the horror of Trump's family
separation policy and was denied entry
under the Harris Administration h i will
end all for-profit detention centers and
ensure kids are where they belong with
their families she can't go down to the
southern border now for some unknown
reason when she went she wasn't even
close to the Border she was in Texas but
Steve I I mean I'm wondering about the
political implications and I want you to
also tell us what can a president do a
different President and Vice President
in the first days or weeks or months of
a new Administration that actually would
make a difference for what bill and
Sarah are seeing and
Reporting let me start with the point
about kids to show how Shameless and
remorseless this Administration is the
number of unaccompanied miners coming
across the border these are people 17
and under who are traveling alone who
are often sold into sexual slavery labor
trafficked and who are put into terribly
inhumane conditions involving sexual
assault and battery the numbers coming
across in those demographics are two and
three times the highest levels recorded
in American history probably half a
million miners have been smuggled or
trafficked across the border without any
adult other than the individual
smuggling or trafficking them those
individuals now by the tens of are
completely lost gone and missing that is
a moral stain on the conscience of this
country for which Joe Biden and KLA
Harris are 100% solely responsible as
for the political risk it is enormous
but it does require the Republican party
to get in the game and do its job to be
on top of this every hour of every day
of every week with the moral urgency
this situation demands and you and I
were there when when President Trump
secured the border and what he handed
over to the next Administration was a
remain in Mexico policy that worked
tremendously safe third agreements that
shut down Asylum fraud border security
Partnerships all around the world to
expedite and speed deportations and
enhanced ice authorities to remove
illegal aliens as rapidly from the
country as humanly possible and of
course title 42 these policies together
sealed that border shot tighter than a
submarine hatch Joe Biden demolished
every single one of those policies by
choice by deliberate design to mass
resettle and release millions of illegal
aliens into this country on day one a
future president as president Trump has
said he would you put back in place
every single one of those policies and
then you begin the process of removing
every single person that Joe Biden
illegally allowed into this country that
is how you seal it shut again Stephen
Miller my former White House colleague
who had immigration and n and border
security in his vast portfolio and Sarah
Carter joining us from Eagle Pass Texas
thank you both very much Merry Christmas
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else